tengo entendido que no existen códigos
de conducta que se apliquen directamente
a los jueces de la Corte Suprema y el
mismo tomas ha venido restando gravedad
al tema pero entonces quién regula
situaciones como estas y además debe
haber una regulación al respecto o es
simplemente cuestión de ética
Mira la Corte Suprema simplemente
funciona por su propio prestigio los
poderes de la Corte Suprema ni siquiera
son específicamente numerados la
Constitución y tampoco se requiere que
tenga un código de ética Pero esto
afecta al prestigio esto afecta el poder
el el el la la fiel que tienen el pueblo
norteamericano hacia su corte cuando ven
que el juez más antiguo está aceptando
regalos por la cantidad de más de medio
millones de dólares de una persona que
dona es uno de los principales donantes
del partido republicano así que aunque
no haya una violación directa de un
código que no existe Sí hay unas
violación de la confianza que el pueblo
norteamericano pone en los jueces de la
Corte Suprema Y a propósito del
prestigio y esta confianza llegan este
tipo de casos a sembrar dudas sobre la
legitimidad de las decisiones que toman
estos magistrados en el alto tribunal
por ejemplo el aborto es una de ellas
efectivamente pero trae algo más
específico Andrés que en este caso la
esposa del juez Thomas estuvo muy activa
en todos los esfuerzos para prolongar la
presidencia del expresidente Trump y
tratando de que no se llevara a cabo en
la certificación de la elección del
presidente biden al mismo tiempo que el
juez tomas estaba oyendo casos
relacionados con los retos a esa
elección en el estado de Arizona el
único juez que apoyó al lado de Trump en
esa decisión fue el juez Thomas en mi
opinión lo menos que debió haber hecho
era no haber participado en ese caso
pero como mencionábamos anteriormente
personajes por ejemplo como la
congresista Alexandra Ocasio Cortés han
venido pedido han venido pidiendo la
renuncia de Thomas que tanto puede
escalar este caso es posible que pueda
derivar en la renuncia del magistrado
es muy temprano todavía para decir y
repito
hay que ver si ha habido en realidad
algún tipo de Bio de violación
específicamente los jueces de la Corte
Suprema no tienen que declarar si se
quedan casas de amigos o si son
invitados almuerzos etcétera y como es
una rama independiente del gobierno
norteamericano las otras dos ramas del
gobierno que son la ejecutiva y la
legislativa no pueden imponerle
condiciones la Corte Suprema se gobierna
a sí mismo y acaba de pasar una una un
nuevo una nueva regulación diciendo de
que tienen que reportar casos como estos
pero hasta ahora no era obligatorio
hacerlo era simplemente la pregunta aquí
es si esto fue una violación de la
confianza si hubo algún tipo de de
petición indebida si se ve que ha habido
alguna relación directa entre este
billonario que ha donado todo esto y
decisiones de la Corte Suprema yo sí
creo que esto pudiera llevar algo mucho
más serio pero por el momento
simplemente esto posiblemente lleve
algún tipo de regulación interna por
parte de la propia Corte Suprema